extraordinary accomplishments come from  doing ordinary things for Extraordinary  periods of time when I was younger my  action showed that I was more impatient  I always was willing to sacrifice what I  had today to get the quick Buck I  thought there was some Shortcut I didn't  know about and I would see the guys on  stages being like this is what we do we  do a lot of it I was like they're just  trying to hold the secrets back and I'm  here to tell you that that is not true  like I wish I could go and shake my  college self and be like if you do one  thing for a very long period of time you  will get very good at it I can't do that  so the next best thing I can do is try  and Shake You by the collar the thing  that makes the action extraordinary is  the commitment to it not the nature of  the action itself it's the fact that you  do it for 23 years that is what  compounds on itself and that not the  action itself is what makes someone  extraordinary